it's going to be given by vital and he's
going to talk about friendly bisections
and body analysis so take it away
uh thanks door
um so I'll be discussing
on
quickly friendly
transactions
and everything I'm discussing today is
joint work with
store who's obviously in the audience
and ashwansa who's a fellow graduate
student at MIT
so I guess let me start by defining the
object of Interest
so
a partition
of the in a
v v into A1 Union A2
of a graph
V with vertices and edges
um is
is an H
friendly
by section
one it's a bisection so by this I just
mean the part sizes are as close as they
can possibly be and they sort of
price action the union is everything and
the intersection is nothing
and two you have the property that every
vertex V has more Neighbors in its own
part than in the other part and H more
neighbors were H is the same here
um
so maybe just pictorially you have a
partition A1 A2
and every vertex here has it has more
Neighbors in its own part than the other
part and has H more
what so
uh yeah so yeah exactly and
um this will also be convenient at some
point uh if uh two holes
uh
for all but a little low of V vertices
call it
and almost
eight-friendly by section
so hopefully the definition is clear and
if at any point something's unclear
please do interrupt me
um so I guess the motivating conjecture
here
was a conjunction of Freddy
I don't think it's actually written down
I think he said he made it in 1988 but
the way I learned this was this is in a
open problems list by Ben green
it's like a collection 100. it's a nice
collection of 100 open problems so if
you sample G from gn1 half
then
G with high probability
has
a zero
an almost
zero friendly bisection
and maybe as a brief comment so if you
remove the word by section you can sort
of ask for this just to hold for any
vertex like for any partition and not
require that they're the same then this
is obvious you can just take sort of any
let's say just take the max cut of the
graph or
of the complement of the graph the max
price
sorry
okay
It's relatively easy without this word
by section
um
and okay maybe as a heuristic of maybe
why zero is sensible well they're
roughly something like two to the N by
sections every vertex is a probability a
half of being okay with respect to Any
Given partition so if all these vertices
were independent then this is something
reasonable
and so
I guess last year in joint work this was
the result
so myself
a few years ago so so first conjecture
is true
and furthermore
one confined
uh
a bisection with
Epsilon n violations
and O Epsilon N squared time
so the proof here is this algorithmic
there is some algorithm that does this
and it succeeds with high probability
so I guess the motivation for this talk
is sort of
well why are these two things here
but basically
so the question is sort of
a is the almost necessary it's actually
unclear what Freddy conjecture here but
this is what was written in Ben's note
and B is zero Sharp
so I gave this sort of bay heuristic
that every vertex is independent but
under the assumption that every vertex
is independent but is that sort of the
sharp thing that's happening
so it turns out um
that neither of these are the case and
for this I I do actually just
I need to Define some irrational
constant oh presumably irrational
concept I don't actually know how to
prove that
um
so let gamma be the number which
satisfies the falling equation
to motivate that
they write this just for concreteness
foreign
Z here is a mean zero variance one
gaussian
so this is some constant it exists the
main theorem is that this constant gives
you the sharp answer so
you're um
um
so as before g-assembled from GN one
half
and fix any Epsilon bigger than zero
uh so one
G with high probability
has a
gamma minus Epsilon Times Square Root n
isection
and two G with high probability has
no gamma plus Epsilon Square
so this is essentially a sharp answer
the question a you don't need any of
these exceptional vertices and B gamma
Times Square Root n is just the sharp
answer for understanding this property
okay
the proof isn't written this way but it
so I guess so remark
the remarkables are clotted by this but
yes you can remove that um but the proof
is not written that way
I should remark that
Dandy gomarnak
OVA
um sort of simultaneously independently
uh proved in analogous result
uh with uh
and the same constant gamma Times Square
Root act so
um it's not a real Mark and yeah
I might discuss the almost at the end
okay
uh I guess so I'll just start with
so I'll make some claims that are in the
proof and then I'll focus on one sort of
aspect of the proof where sort of
Boolean functions enters in but to do
that let's maybe let's maybe start with
the proof of this theorem so this is
really a lie but whatever
foreign
we're going to try to do maybe the first
thing you would the first thing maybe
you might believe might work which is
let's actually just try the first and
second moment method here okay so let X
of gamma tilde B the number of
bisections
G and one half I'm sampling G from G and
one up uh which are
Prime Times root and
uh friendly
so to prove the second part of the
statement we're just going to apply the
first moment method so okay
so first if gamma tilde is bigger than
this threshold gamma plus Epsilon what
we prove is that the expectation of X of
gamma tilde
this is exponentially small
together
once you have this claim part two is
just the first moment method
okay
unfortunately we're not so lucky for
part one
for
for below this threshold well okay we're
going to try to use the second moment
method
and the proof sort of naturally or
the proof if you do it the way we do
sort of loses a constant
um
so you get something like this
and okay uh so then given that the first
and second moments match up to constants
something like the Paley zigmund
inequality
implies
the probability that say what we care
about is z this random variable being
positive let's say at least half of its
expectation
you can check is bigger than one
um this is greater than or equal to some
constant
but it's not
it's greater than some constant but it's
not with high probability
so if I wanted to prove that theorem
without with with just with high uh just
with constant probability this moment
computation suffices
okay
um because most of the rest of the talk
will be sort of discussing how to remove
this condition but maybe briefly
um so these quantities are so this is
not so obvious called mutation
um and maybe maybe a brief bit why so
these quantities naturally live on some
exponential scale so I'm saying that I
can look at a graph and sort of
just for the expectation there's some
exponentially small probability that a
given partition will be a friendly
bisection and I'm telling you that then
I can estimate this probability to
within let's say at least a constant
Factor
naively this seems like a relatively
hard task maybe even a little bit
hopeless
but it turns out that there are ways to
maybe think about this
the sort of key Insight maybe the
starting point for all these
computations is that
um the condition
of uh
of a bipartition
uh being
friendly
is only a function of of the degree
sequence
particular I can look at every vertex on
each side and sort of look at their
degree into this part and to the other
part
I can record that information and just
count the number of graphs of that form
amazingly we have tools for this so
there's quite nice work of McKay and
wormald I think this is from 88 but
essentially tells you how to count such
things it's based on complex analysis
after that there's still quite a lot of
work you sort of need to see this
magical constant this comes out of
comparing this with a certain doubtion
model and realizing that the computation
is exactly the same and then you need to
figure out some way to enumerate over
such all such degrees sequences that's
the
a large part of the Tactical work so
this gives you the expectation
the expectation squared is something
similar
two partitions
um
but
after this point there's still quite a
lot of work but I don't want to focus on
that for the rest of the talk
and maybe a brief remark It Won't Be
True in general that something like a
first and second moment method will
actually capture
the truth of the threshold here
um so this is a this is kind of a very
special thing that's happening it's
happening due to sort of
how sort of you look at the set of
bisections which are valid for a
different graph G they sort of form a
very nice subset in particular they're
kind of well separated and
um all the way up to the threshold and
this sort of is what plausibly makes it
possible to apply the second development
method
the second moment message
yeah and then you so yeah you need to
enter numerate over it so somehow
they're really like 10 parts of this
graph or a lot so
um oh I guess there was also yeah
so I guess
and also I raised this but the first and
second moment don't match up to
constants for there's some numerical
concept that comes out of the proof
in reality if you think about it pretty
hard on what's happening with the
physics of the model almost certainly
these things actually don't match up to
a constant there should be a constant
Factor deviation
either figure out how to remove that
there might be ways to do this
or you can try to just like bootstrap a
result for free and well there's one
nice way to do this to try to use
Boolean functions and sort of remove
this so there are many theorems of this
form something like that theorem or
um
percolation but it's not
there's so no varying P here it's not
immediately clear how buoyed functions
will enter the picture but
that's sort of the upshot here so maybe
let's just try some naive concentration
attempt first and sort of see where we
get
so for the rest of the talk I'm sort of
going to think of
think of G and one half as just a random
subset a random subset of zero one a
random string in 0 1 to the entries two
by identifying edges with n choose two
and so we know that let's say the
measure of f
is greater greater than one where F
corresponds to graphs
which have
a friendly bisection
this is just an equivalent way of
writing the conclusion of the second
method on the other board
so given this I mean let's maybe
consider
if you're going to view this as a subset
of the hypercube let's considered the
most natural distance
so
so this here is just the hemming
distance on the hypercube I'm going to
sample a graph G from GN one half
and I'm going to look at the distance of
G from this family f
so what is it typically
well okay so this is it turns out just
to be founded by something like n this
is just because the probability that
this distance is zero
this is greater than some constant and
then you can either use vertex ions or
perimetry or something like Azuma
hopping to show an inequality like this
also already gives you something pretty
non-trivial so you can find a bicep you
can find a bisection
um
[Music]
missing
most
with say
something like square root and bad
vertices
where by bad vertices I mean vertices
which violate being a friendly bisection
this is just because in order to make a
single vertex bad you sort of need to
change square root and edges at that
vertex and if you're only moving by
distance then you can only make this
many bad and this is a pretty
non-trivial thing this is why almost is
somehow much easier it's because you
have these like strong concentration
measure tools which are available to you
but if we want to get exactly friendly
we'll need to do something more
um and the main thing is we sort of for
forgotten maybe the key fact about this
family and what we're aiming for so
somehow the having metric is maybe not
the right metric here we don't really
care about the number of edges you
change we do care about how these edges
that you change are distributed
throughout the graph
so
so that's the first thing
the rest of the talk will be sort of
discussing this
so for this
um
I'm going to define the dist between two
graphs I apologize in advance for bad
notation but
um
so this is the max degree
and then I look at my two graphs and I
look at the symmetric difference between
them
so
these are graphs I look at a symmetric
difference I look at the max degree
the reason this is maybe the right
metric if you care about this problem is
that sort of
if this distance is small
and let's say G has
and age friendly bisection
as an S friend in my section then h
has a s minus 2T friendly bisection
so somehow this metric is capturing
exactly the notion you want to know you
you just want to know how many vertices
I change at a match
and the main theorem is sort of all you
need about f
um for for our result is that f is a
symmetric friendly because the property
of a graph having a friendly bisection
is obviously symmetric under permuting
its vertices it turns out that's all you
need
so let me just take that there formally
um
suppose you have F which is a subset of
zero one to and choose two
um
that is SN
variant
and the measure of f
is bigger than Epsilon
then probability that
dist tilde of
G from the family F so here I just mean
the minimum distance is something in the
large family for example G from GM one
half
that this is greater than a c log one
over Epsilon
so square root n over log n
this is less than Epsilon
and so this immediately proves the
result we want because take Epsilon
tending to uh
tending to zero slowly square root n
over log n times I'm slowly growing
function is still a little low of square
root n
and we have gamma times square root of n
root so given this the result is
assuming that you believe this
computation
just one remark before going on also
that was a good time for
questions
um this is this statement is the
statement is sharp
in uh
and Epsilon and like the one over square
root log dependence
and it comes from a rather natural
example what you do is you consider the
set of graphs which have atypically high
maximum degree
roughly having maximum degree like you
look at the median maximum degree having
maximum degree this much higher occurs
with probability Epsilon and to change
the max degree you need to change you
need to change the edges at that vertex
so somehow this suggests that if
something that looks like a dictator
something like a dictator type thing
so maybe that suggests that Boolean
function should be relevant
okay
yeah so I guess for the rest of the talk
the goal is to just prove that theorem
so
is there any questions
approximately
uh I think it's like I think it's like
0.71 you can compute it to basically
arbitrary position
um there's an easy fix Point procedure
that gives it to like however many
decimal places you want but
it's smaller
yes
okay so I guess now I'm just going to
recall a bunch of Boolean function
definitions I'm just going to keep them
on the board so that I have access to
the rest of the talk
so
so as a standard you define the
influence of bi of coordinate to be the
probability that switching
the value of the I coordinate sort of
switching the IIT values the coordinate
changes the value
um
the total influence is just the sum of
these all these influences over
you sum over all the coordinates what is
the influence
also need the notion of sort of the
positive sensitivity so I have a point x
in the hypercube the positive
sensitivity is just the sensitivity
given that the point is not in the set
so or you can think of functions that
obviously sets and other zero one value
just sets
foreign
ly the main result we'll need is a
quantity relating sort of the positive
sensitivity to the influence and the
variance of the function f so this is a
theorem of
Eldon and gross
it was a simpler proof given by Eldon
Kinsler
shots
what we need is that
the square root of this sensitivity
the expected value of this is at least
sort of the variance of f so this is a
natural quantity because somehow like
this is telling you the number of
coordinates you can change sort of um
like this tells you to probably kind of
like change and but you pick up some
Factor based on uh the total or the sum
of the sum of the squares of the
influences
square root of log of one plus one over
someone
this goes under another
there's a constant hiding here
[Music]
foreign
unfortunately the first step of this
proof is a little bit uninspiring the
first step is to sort of get yourself
into you you want to derive some
combinatorial decomposition using this
on like functions which are symmetric
I'm just going to State the lemon that
you've given the proof sure
I'm going to fix Epsilon in zero to one
half
and let the expectation of f
so one of the following three scenarios
occurs
either you have that
with decent probability over the cube
that
um
that at a given vertex that you can sort
of there's a coordinate you can switch
so that um
so that you're okay so the correct
threshold turns out to be Epsilon log n
over n
two um
two and three will look very similar
what it will say is that instead of just
trying to look at the probability that
you have large positive sensitivity
you're going to vary you're sort of
going to try to balance the pro this
probability against the number of large
coordinates you have against the number
of vertices that have
um that many positive influence that
many positive changes appropriately so
more precisely
um
there is J
such that
2 to the J times the probability
s f plus of X is in 2 to the J to 2 to
the J plus one
this is bigger than oh I'm also going to
lose like log log factors over the
result I promised but I'm I'm not
not moving those
a little more cleverness with this
decomposition
finally
um
there exists J such that
one it lies in some specific interval
which will be relevant later
um
and uh 2 to the J over 2 times the
probability that SF plus is in
the J 2 to the J plus one
this is greater than or equal to Epsilon
times
square root log over a log that's not a
probability it's some number
and the proof of this is just like these
two quantities basically tell you the
sensitivity in the square root of
sensitivity and we're just going to
derive some inequalities based on that
nothing particularly deep is going to
happen at this point
so the total influence is just the sum
or J bigger than zero
2 to the J times the probability that
positive influences between
2 to the J and 2 to the J plus one cool
so there are a couple cases
so one
if I of f is bigger than let's say
something like
10 to the one-half times some light
large fact get rid of 100 there okay
I suppose this is pretty large maybe
there's some batted buckets in which
you're okay
so this case check mark
bad practice I'm not going to just
reverse the inequality sign so we can
assume that for the rest of the proof
um so this gives you something I need to
use this inequality so I'm going to now
bound to some of the influences squared
this is the one place symmetry comes in
because we know it's symmetric we know
that all the influences Square all these
influences are the same
this is just the total influence
divided by entries two and if you plug
this in this this is less than n to the
minus one-half say
um so in particular this lets you derive
that the expectation of the square root
of the sensitivity
this is at least Epsilon times
square root of log n
that's just like that's just using the
theorem of ldot and grosser the other
authors
okay we can also now assume that the
first condition doesn't occur
otherwise
kind of by definition we're done
so SF plus is uh greater than zero well
this is less than or equal to
Epsilon square root log n
now the last part is you just write out
what uh this expression is so this is
the sum
for convenience I'm just gonna let this
be W of J so it's 2 to the minus J over
2 times W of J
um so we know
this is this is literally the square
root of the sensitivity up to a constant
so this is bigger than Epsilon times
square root of log n
and so I have to sum over 2 to the J
which goes between like 1 and the number
of coordinates which is like n choose
two
so first where are we going to use this
condition that the probability of having
an having a coordinate which you can
switch is small well this just tells you
that the small terms in the sum don't
contribute very much
so
um this is basically equivalent
to you can kick out terms which are less
than let's say n
so we've eliminated that much
the second half is that well we know
that the total
we know that the total influence is
bounded by n to the one-half times some
log power well okay anything bigger than
n times some large power of log this 2
to the minus J over 2 is something like
root n so root n times this if you if
you choose like you make the 2 to the J
between n Times log into a million up
log into some large power then this is
also approximately the same as like
summer
I might have lied on the constants but
whatever and now there are just log log
pieces in the static some one of them
will satisfied at the bottom
anymore
great
so
so is that clear
okay so given this we're going to sort
of do some like we're gonna try to prove
the main theorem sort of by like
bootstrapping off this comp like there's
some combinatorial bootstrap off this
back which will give us the final result
I will now proceed to erase the board I
just wrote
well I need two parts
yeah sorry oh I think you said it didn't
write it yeah
I think
thanks yeah
based on which one of these holes so
so okay let's maybe yeah so maybe figure
let's pause it for a second so somehow I
need to get
I need to show the stock that like I
have some family which is a set of
Epsilon I need to show that somehow
there's some like small maybe bounded
like small and degree perturbation of it
which sort of gets me to this family
typically
so what I'm going to try to do is sort
of use these cases to sort of grow my
family slowly
um to some larger set and then once I've
wrote it I want to then verify that
through this growing procedure I can
sort of find a certificate in the
original set which shows that I'm still
close in maximum degree
it requires a
the perfect the proof required is a
little bit of work but okay let's let's
maybe start along the path
the issue sort of this setup will make a
good way be the fitness is
so we consider a set of expansions
so
um just for concreteness so F0 will will
start up at a family at zero which is
just going to be equal path
and FJ will be the J family
okay will be
Kate family
so I'll think of like capital f as a
subset of
as a subset of like 0 1 to the N choose
two
and all of these will be families of
graphs so they'll be asset and varying
um also just so I can cite the indicator
facts so like little FK will just be the
indicator of uh
capital F okay
and by assumption we're going to look at
mu of f 0 which is going to be Epsilon
and what I'm going to try to do is go
from Epsilon to two Epsilon and that's
enough you just repeat like log one over
Epsilon times you double you're done
so that's all I'm gonna
so
we're not going to have too much control
on the family FK so we're just going to
try to expand using one of these
conditions
so
so there's going to be algorithm one
which or a step one between algorithm
one so if the probability of sfj plus is
greater than zero
is greater than Epsilon times square
root of log n over root n
then I'm just going to Define
FJ to be f j minus 1 Union the points
which size its condition X such that s f
plus of x
is greater than zero
so that's step one that's the first
algorithm
the second algorithm will be
move it over
it'd be 2 2 J
so uh there is
A J such that um
2 to the J times the probability that SF
plus is in 2 to the J to
2 to the J plus one
and this is bigger than this like funny
threshold I wrote earlier
uh then I'm just then you just Define FJ
in the obvious way once again you just
take the points X which exhibit this
oh okay sorry it's great oh okay
now I think F and J's are hopefully
distinguishable our F and K's are
hopefully signature
plus is in
okay
um
3j
the same thing
so you have your family at this step you
look at its corresponding function you
look at the corresponding a function you
know one of these three applies
find one of them that applies and sort
of expand the family using the
definition
okay
foreign
goes on forever I'm just going to define
a termination condition
terminate uh when
uh the measure of mu of f k
is greater than 2 Epsilon
so naively I don't really have any sort
of control on how long this algorithm
runs but you
the thing we're going to prove is the
obvious thing
at the end every put every graph in FK I
think you've using a notation here every
graph here is in this distance tilde
metric uh square root n log n from some
graph in the original if you have that
you're done
so let's
well let's try to at least get some
control on the algorithm the way we're
going to get control is we're just going
to say okay how many times can you do
each of these steps that's maybe the
first step
L1
well how many times can this run
well every time you if this is true
the measure of the family went up by
Epsilon square root log n over n and I'm
trying to go to 2 Epsilon
so
um
there are
at most
square root n over log n
such
such steps
we're also just going to use the same
Bound for these two steps
so how many times can we run the Second
Step well now we know that
well the measure doesn't go up by
Epsilon times square root of n that's
bigger than one presumably but it goes
up by at least two to the minus J times
Epsilon times squared n Times log into
100. so it turns out
there are most
to the J over square root n
sometimes okay
100 steps
of 3j
okay
um now it's helpful that I at least have
this written here
um
so they're at most uh two to the J over
two times
with log N squared over square root log
n stops
once again these two facts are just
because every time you apply this step
you know that the measure goes by so
much and we're just trying to get to two
up Cylon
so now I have to it's a I've done this
little setup and I've like written
things down with SF plus I I do actually
need to use this somewhere and the key
Point here is going to be that you can
balance
um balance sort of if 2 to the J is very
very large let's say N squared I mean
this is n to the three half steps so n
to the three half steps means like you
could completely destroy a vertex so you
need you need to use something about SF
plus what you're going to ultimately use
is that you know that you have many
choices
and for this well I'm now going to draw
a picture that looks very backwards
so I need some notation for the stopping
time of this process like the last time
that's just going to be Tau
I'm now going to draw extremely
backwards for some reason
so
so I just want to show that every point
in SF tau is somehow close to some point
in s uh sorry every point in F tau is
somehow close to some point in F0 in
this metric uh dist tilde
um let's assume basically without loss
of generality that the so notice that at
every step we're sort of keeping the old
family and just sort of increasing it
um let's pretend that we know that the
graph G that we care about gets added at
the last step
I'm not really assuming anything here
okay
so somehow I want to like
look at the Paw
and the history of how it got added
right
notice that every time you get added
there is a graph in the previous family
you're either the same as some graph in
the previous family or there's a graph
in the previous family which is somehow
close to you in particular you've
changed exactly one Edge
okay
so I'm what I'm going to do is I'm going
to construct a path
but going backwards and these two facts
plus that as we know that SF plus is
sufficiently large will be n
so let's maybe do this
so at every step there's some like label
for this step it's like an ALG one step
or like an ALG 2J step or let's say an
owl
3j step so I'm just going to sort of
bound the max like the number of changes
sort of and the change to the max degree
that happens from each of these steps
separately
so
I'll go on
only happens
uh
and over log n times
so this doesn't change the max degree
doesn't cause enough change
now let's look at how to the j-step
so what do I mean by look at a step so
I'm going to construct sort of what I'm
going to do is I'm going to sort of
construct a history of edges going
backwards that are sufficient to change
and to get from here to the final thing
and that like history of change edges
will be sufficient
so at some point I have an ALK 2 to the
J step
[Music]
so
there are at most
say 2 to the J over square root n
Times log n to the hundred
such edges that I've changed earlier
this is just because that's the total
number of steps so how many of these
have high degree
so so there are less than or equal to 2
to the J so this is like look at the
graph induced by the chain you've
constructed a history so far look at the
set of edges you've changed due to out
to J
how many of those how many vertices in
that auxiliary graph have degree above
square root n Times log n
they're at most 2 to the J divided by n
times
log n to the 100 uh High degree vertices
in this graph
so
so this is the complete graph if you
have a set of vertices the number of
edges possibly emanating out of there is
like 2 to the J
divided by log n to the 100
bad edges you can't add
and now we're done at least for this
step because at this point if you got
added an out 2J step
you know that your SF plus is between 2
to the J and 2 to the J Plus 1.
so there are a bunch of bad edges which
correspond potentially to high degree
vertices but it's okay you have enough
choices
and I'll also verify this for the final
step
so so it acts to sort of continue this
history backwards so I want to construct
a certificate of edges that I can change
going backwards so that if I look at the
set of edges which have correspond to
like out2j Steps at every step that
graph is bound in maximum degree like as
bounded degree the point here is what
I'm saying is that okay look at the
number of vertices of this graph which
have high degree degree above Ruden
there are very few of them because of
this there are very few bad choices for
me there's almost a number of high
degree vertices times n
but I know that since this came from
this step SF plus is large it's larger
than 2J so I have some way of continuing
this history backwards that's enough
and for alc3j it's similar
I'll just do the computation it's
so
there are most this many steps so
number of vertices
by degree
this divided by Ruden so it's less than
or equal to 2 to the J over two
over
we're done
well again some like log logs or
something
and so uh
yeah so how many changes do I have I
know that I have at least two to the J
changes like possible changes
and I'm going to multiply the number of
bad like possible choices like 2 to the
J over 2 times root n divided by like
log cabin
so and if you rearrange this is like
certainly if two to the J is bigger than
that and this is fine
and we guarantee this here
so you can always just construct this
history backwards
so instead of looking forward you look
backwards and that's enough
and with that I mean that's the whole
proof I mean I slightly lied you need to
maintain that like you can sum the
degrees but I have lots of room like I
have like logs of room here and there's
only one login such graphs here so it's
fine
okay
um are there any questions
if not I'll just leave with like one
maybe one open problem which I think is
quite interesting here
um
so first you do
you do yeah you get it's a concentration
Supply yeah
and maybe just just as an open question
that I think is actually quite
interesting
so can one find
um algorithmically
a 10 to the minus 10
squared and friendly bisection with high
probability
if you want
I'm willing to put it almost there
it's not fair how to do this because
this proof is purely existential
but with that um that's all I have to
say
is this related
uh yes I mean so this uh yeah this is
the apologies this was his conjecture
and it's just compared okay and this was
the this is the resolution of polar
cross conjecture but there's a genotype
icon which is not super small and it's
slightly expanded and then it's almost
everybody
that's it
uh I mean like stronger than isoprometry
well this is interesting view
um what's understanding equality because
there are several things like this
yes
oh sorry yes
so this is the thing that he started I
mean this is uh
it's like an improvement of those things
ah yes yeah
into the point of having metric is the
wrong metric or at least this problem
is
it accepted GMP
for Peak constant yes for p like little
one so the almost thing is still true
um
don't quote me on display think the
first and second moment almost only
start to differ right more it's
extremely unclear actually to me what I
I suspect it's true
um so a lot of this right a lot of this
gets harder and that part also the first
second moment it's not actually clear
like I think people start losing factors
in B
yeah it's not an old player it's just a
threshold the same for different peers
so it's the same um it's the same in the
sense that what you should do is you
should be normalize you should do like
gamma Times Square Root n times like P
times one minus B if
times two
and this will be the thing in general at
least for constantly this follows almost
immediately for the proof
but for smaller piece it's very unfair
it breaks at some point obviously but I
think basically as long as the question
makes sense it should be true
but so there's another technique in
random graph Theory generally think
where the bank is too large or you
conditioned on something yes so I don't
want to discuss this but so the reason
so what you do is this is generated by
the small group like smart scraps it's
called small subgraph condition you're
gonna apply
you would let's say at least need to
know how to prove a central limit
theorem for small graphs and degree
consumer random graphs
that's not easy slash obvious but
whatever you can do the opposite and
then we can use this kind of
concentration to
I mean so frequency theorem will like
serves that purpose on a lot of
applications right like in sports crafts
do you often use three grip to just
remove the small sub conditioning in
terms of this is like a dead title the
write down analog here for us um
yeah
I think that answering the question was
it more precise different regime this
results are in the smart city and this
is
yeah so it turns out
almost certainly the like pause for
these like small these like deviations
are similar deviations and small stuff
graphs it turns out um there are related
models where it's just shown by
um
Sly and co-authors the symmetric
perceptron model
um and there you can you can use some
version of small sub graph conditioning
but they use very strongly that they're
in captions
um it's very hard to do that it's
extremely unparated that's pretty good
random props it's probably also very
painful
okay so normal questions let's thank
Meetup again
and we'll meet in 30 minutes for the
last talk